so the women over on The View were um
squawking this week about free speech
and I want to go through
a couple of these clips first of all
here's Whoopi Goldberg announcing
um tragically that she's leaving Twitter
it has been a little over a week since
Elon Musk took over Twitter and places
it it's a mess he's already called back
some of the workforce he fired a few
days ago he's putting his Eight dollar
charge for blue check verification on
hold first it was going to be twenty
dollars now it's going to be eight
dollars he also suspended Kathy Griffin
for impersonating him on a parody
account uh
which has started a free Cappy hashtag
to Trent I mean I'm I'm I I'm getting
off I'm getting off today because I just
feel like you know it's it's so messy
yeah and I I'm tired of now
having had certain kinds of attitudes
blocked and now they're back on and I
just I'm gonna get out and if it settles
down and I feel more comfortable yeah
maybe I'll come back but as of tonight
I'm done with Twitter
of course Mo if you're like me you hear
that and you think uh uh oh you were on
Twitter I didn't even know that like
what are the what are the I I just want
to know in if I can get in their own
head get in their heads which is not
really a place I'd want to be but well
how do you think people are going to
react to this do you think people are
you're making some big dramatic
announcement I'm done you know I might
be back later but I just for now I'm out
of there which by the way when it comes
to dramatic announcements that's uh
that's that's
kind of an anticlimactic way to go about
it
I'm done I mean I might come back later
but I'm done for now I will not be on
Twitter again until at least tomorrow
morning if not a little bit sooner but
at this moment right now I'm not gonna
be I am not using Twitter at this moment
while I'm on TV
what do they expect do they think that
people are gonna
like the people think it's good that
Elon Musk took over Twitter are they
gonna say well never mind I mean if this
scares uh Whoopi Goldberg away I can't
imagine Twitter without Whoopi Goldberg
and then you also see once again just
the total absolute fragility of these
people
she says oh all these people that were
they were I was insulated for them from
them and now and now they're
their ideas are going to be I'm going to
maybe be exposed to some of their ideas
and opinions and their words
and I can't I
I can't deal with that
does it make sense that the same company
who controls half of online retail also
eavesdrops on your private conversations
at home or the company that controls 90
of all internet Searchers searches also
runs your email service and tracks
everything you do on your smartphone big
Tech is more powerful than most
countries these days and they profit by
exploiting your personal data put a
layer of protection between your online
activity and big Tech with expressvpn
think about how much of your life is on
the internet every site you visit video
you watch message you send gets tracked
data mined but when you run expressvpn
on your device the software hides your
IP address making your activity a lot
more difficult to trace expressvpn also
encrypts 100 of your internet data to
keep you safe from hackers and
eavesdroppers what I like most about
expressvpn is how easy it is to use
download the app
on your phone computer tap one button
and your protective expressvpn does all
this without slowing your connection
stop handing over your personal data to
the big Tech Monopoly who Minds your
activity and sells your information
protect yourself with the VPN that I
trust to keep me safe online visit
expressvpn.com mattwallshow and get
three extra months for free that's
expressvpn.com Matt walshow
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show
she also has some thoughts on the nature
of free speech I think this is in clip
six
Communications act which a lot which
basically allows this to happen I think
it's section 230. it allows
um you know protection of social media
at different platforms well they just
say that they're they're third-party
platforms they're not the ones that are
putting it out there and that can only
change by legislation and if the
Republicans rule the sentence so it's a
bit challenging because if you treat it
like a publication then that means
they're liable for any crazy thing
someone says well it is
they keep saying that it's free speech
and some speech is not all for all
speeches not free speech some speech is
not okay free speech so everybody has to
agree on that but if people keep saying
well you remember Free Speech it's going
to be a problem but you know what
this is going to be this is our problem
but ain't my problem today
some speech is not okay free speech
that's that's it so that you know
there's been this debate for centuries
really about about Free Speech what is
Free Speech what counts is Free Speech
and um is Free Speech absolute and
Whoopi Goldberg has I guess settled
settled the debate entirely
she says that you know some speech is
just not okay
and how do we know if it's not okay or
not I guess she'll tell us
meanwhile although this maybe has been a
debate
I've never found the debate all that
interesting because to me now they're
always around the margins they're always
going to be the harder kind of cases but
for the most part you know when you with
like 99.9 of all the speech that goes on
it it's it's really easy to to determine
whether it quote counts as free speech
or whether it ought to count as free
speech or not
okay and the things that shouldn't count
as free speech generally speaking if
you're making direct violent threats
against someone actual threats
and using a pronoun you don't like
that's not a threat
disagreeing with you is not a threat
saying something like I'm gonna come to
your house and kill you like saying the
things the trans activists say to me
almost every day
that's a threat that's clearly a threat
so that's not free speech at least it
shouldn't be
um trying to explicitly encourage other
people
to cause harm to someone or to commit a
crime
again that clearly shouldn't count as
free speech
uh defamation
right slander liable any any in any form
of speech written or spoken
where you're lying about someone in
order to cause them harm
not free speech
and those are pretty much all the
exceptions
you might be able to come up with a few
here and there but you you know what the
exceptions are when you see them
it's it's pretty rare when you come
across an actual hard case of trying to
determine oh does that qualify as free
speech or not because again I think 99.9
of it we all know
and most of the speech that goes on on
social media it's uh people might be
vulgar they might be
you know they might be cruel they might
be rude
but they're essentially just expressing
their opinion and if you're expressing
your opinion
that's free speech and that ought to be
allowed on social media
ought to be allowed on Twitter if
Twitter is saying I mean if Twitter is
saying that they've got if Elon Musk is
saying is a commitment to free speech
that's what he's saying that's he wants
to run his company then that means that
people should be able to simply just
Express their ideas and their opinions
and that's it
and if you don't like what someone says
You can disagree with them you can even
block them there's a lot you can choose
not to read it there are a lot of ways
around it
but to me it's not all that difficult
let people speak let them voice their
opinions
that's it that's all that'll do it for
this portion of the show as you move
over to the members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]